in Zanzibar you can find many of the
world's spices but the times when you
could get rich from trading these spices
are long gone before all the farmers in
the area depended on tourists if no one
visited the firm it was difficult to
survive a lot of them had to give up and
looked for other work together with his
neighbor's spice farmer Patrick Magana
has managed to corner a new market among
the Spice farmers of Zanzibar is
considered an expert and all the others
come to him to buy new seedlings I think
it's because I exclusively use cow dung
and select the plants very carefully
along with 30 other spice farmers my
Ganga founded a cooperative since then
the farmers have shared everything tools
labor and above all knowledge together
they've found a way to expand cloves are
now growing on a large scale
my Ganga's neighbor Ali Foam explains
how the approach led to success we
decided to be certified organic and when
we sell to our customer as organic the
price is increased yeah
from 15 to to 20,000 two shillings the
cooperative is a young company based in
stone town it seeks out organic products
from the island all the spices are
hand-picked and then shipped to Europe
for Okaloosa is pleased with the close
cooperation with the farmers market they
have exactly they know where they can
sell their stuff also even the
production's little bit higher and last
year it was about 2 500 the sibling of
the clove they were already part so
probably after 2 years such a harvest
two more 500 new plants Patrick
McGonagle has been able to build a new
house with the additional income his
wife is very happy I'm very proud of him
life is much easier than before and the
family gets everything it needs more and
more people who have seen how successful
we are with the organization now come
here it's the only way to make good
money around here in this area be
childish about the bubbles his oldest
son now has his own small family my
Ganga is hoping to use the profits from
the next harvest to build him a house